.
>> Rachel: LESS THAN A YEAR INTO
THIS ADMINISTRATION, THE ONE
THING THAT JOE BIDEN'S
PRESIDENCY HAS ALREADY TAUGHT US
IS THAT HE HAS NO RESPECT FOR
LIFE.
WE SAW IT WHEN BIDEN CHECKED HIS
WATCH AS THE BODIES OF AMERICAN
SOLDIERS WERE PRESENTED TO
GRIEVING FAMILIES.
THEIR LIVES CUT SHORT AT THE
COST OF HIS AWFUL DECISIONS IN
AFGHANISTAN.
AND THEN HE MADE IT ALL ABOUT
HIMSELF WHEN HE SPOKE TO THOSE
GOLD STAR FAMILIES AS ONE OF
THOSE FATHERS RECALLED.
>> HE TALKED A BIT MORE ABOUT
HIS OWN SON THAN HE DID MY SON,
AND THAT DIDN'T SIT WELL WITH
ME.
>> Rachel: AND WE SEE IT IN HIS
WAR ON THE UNBORN, WHERE HE IS
PUSHING HIS DOJ TO OVERRULE
TEXAS' ABORTION LAW THAT
PROTECTS THE LIVES OF BABIES IN
THE WOMB.
JOE BIDEN SOLD HIMSELF AS THE
EMPATHIZER IN CHIEF BUT THE LAST
FEW WEEKS HAVE SHOWN JOE BIDEN
TO BE ANYTHING BUT EMPATHETIC.
JOINING ME NOW IS FORMER VICE
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE AND
ALASKA GOVERNOR SARAH PALIN.
WELCOME, GOVERNOR.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> Rachel: AS A MOTHER OF A
VETERAN, TELL ME WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT HOW JOE BIDEN, PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAS TREATED THE MILITARY
SINCE HE HAS BEEN ELECTED?
>> IT'S A SHAME.
AND THOSE IN THE MILITARY
CANDIDLY BOLDLY EXPRESSED THEIR
OPINION, THEY SHARE THAT OPINION
THAT THIS IS A SHAME THAT THEIR
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF, THEIR LEADER
WOULD BE SO BLAIZE ABOUT LIVES
OF AMERICAN'S FINEST WHO ARE
SERVING, SOMETHING GREATER THAN
SELF.
THEY LITERALLY ARE SERVING.
PEOPLE WHO, THOUGH, WHO HAVE
SUFFERED UNDERNEATH THE HANDS OF
JOE BIDEN, ARE VERY FRUSTRATED.
I THINK A LOT OF THEM FEEL
DEFENSELESS.
THEY FEEL HELPLESS, EVEN, IN
WONDERING HEY, IS THE REST OF
AMERICA GOING TO BE OUTRAGED,
ALSO, AND SAY ENOUGH IS ENOUGH?
AND DO SOMETHING ABOUT THIS IN
THE COLLECTIVE RISING UP?
AND ACTUALLY DOING SOMETHING
ABOUT THE PROBLEMS THAT THE
LEFTISTS ARE CAUSING, INCLUDING
JUST DISSEMINATING THE MORALE,
DISSEMINATING THE ORGANIZATION
THAT IS OUR MILITARY.
>> Rachel: YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK A LOT OF AMERICANS SHARE
WHAT YOU JUST SAID.
I THINK THEY REALLY FEEL THAT
WAY.
IT'S NOT RESONATING WITH OUR
MEDIA WHO IS TRYING TO TELL THE
STORY AND TURN THE PAGE.
YOU KNOW, I CAN'T GET -- I HAVE
TO GET BACK TO WHAT I SAID IN MY
INTRO.
I THINK JOE BIDEN WAS SOLD AS
THE EMPATHIZER IN CHIEF.
AND SOMEBODY WITH A LOT OF
COMPASSION.
NOW WE SEE HIM IN THE TEXAS
HEARTBEAT BILL, HE IS USING --
HE IS ACTUALLY USING HIS
ADMINISTRATION.
USING HIS DOJ TO GO AFTER
PRO-LIFERS, PEOPLE WHO ARE JUST
TRYING TO PROTECT THE UNBORN,
TRYING TO PROTECT THE DISABLED
AND THOSE WITH SPECIAL NEEDS WHO
ARE OFTEN THE VICTIMS OF
ABORTION.
WHAT DOES ALL OF THIS, ALL
TOGETHER, SAY ABOUT JOE BIDEN'S
MORAL COMPASS?
>> WELL, DO WE SEE A PATTERN
HERE?
WE DO.
HE WHO WOULD NOT EMBRACE A CULL
YOU ARE IT OF LIFE, NOT
UNDERSTANDING HIS CATHOLIC FAITH
EVEN HEY, WHERE ARE THE BISHOPS
IN ALL OF THIS BY THE WAY?
BUT, HIS CATHOLIC FAITH AND ANY
JUDE DEO CHRISTIAN, EVEN, YOU
KNOW, AGNOSTIC BELIEF IN HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO PROTECT THE
INNOCENT, TO PROTECT THE
DEFENSELESS.
JOE BIDEN -- THAT DOESN'T
RESONATE WITH HIM.
AND WE SEE THAT IN HIS
PRO-ABORTION STANCE, WE SEE THAT
IN WHAT HE HAS DONE WITH
AMERICANS IN AFGHANISTAN.
YOU KNOW, THIS -- SOME THINK
THIS IS A STRETCH, IT'S NOT.
WE CAN EQUATE THIS CULTURE OF
DEATH THAT HAS BEEN ACCEPTED BY
TOO MANY ON THE LEFT THAT BEING
SNUFF OUT THE LIFE OF AN
INNOCENT CHILD IN THE WOMB, AND
WE CAN SEE NOW A CULTURE THAT IS
ALLOWING OTHERS OPPORTUNITY TO
CREATE DEATH AROUND INNOCENT
PEOPLE, SPEAKING OF AFGHANISTAN.
SO, IF AMERICANS ARE GOOD WITH
THIS, THEN WE'RE GOING TO SEE IT
CONTINUE.
AND IT IS A SLIPPERY SLOPE.
WE CAN SEE WHAT'S COMING NEXT.
BUT AMERICANS ARE SAYING NO,
THIS GOES AGAINST EVERYTHING
THAT WE BELIEVE IN TERMS OF
UNDERSTANDING HUMAN LIFE AND
GOD'S CREATION AND THE
PURPOSEFULNESS OF EVERY CHILD
AND EVERY INNOCENT PERSON WHO
HAPPENS TO BE ABANDONED IN
AFGHANISTAN RIGHT NOW, AGAIN,
THE TWO ISSUES DO CORRELATE.
>> Rachel: THEY DO.
>> ENOUGH PEOPLE SAY WE'RE NOT
GOING TO PUT UP WITH THIS.
NO LONGER WILL WE HAVE LEADERS.
WE WILL UNELECT THESE LEADERS
WHO ARE CREATING THIS SLIPPERY
SLOPE WE ARE ON.
>> Rachel: GOVERNOR, I WANT TO
ASK YOU ABOUT SOMETHING ELSE.
THERE IS ANOTHER CATHOLIC WHO IS
PROMINENT AND COMING OUT AGAINST
THE HEARTBEAT BILL IN TEXAS.
HER NAME IS AOC.
SHE SAID THIS I WANT TO GET YOUR
REACTION TO IT BECAUSE IT'S A
LITTLE BIT KOOKY.
LET ME PLAY THE CLIP.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF IS HE
FAMILIAR WITH A MEN STRAGHT
PERSON'S BODY.
I DO KNOW HE IS NOT FAMILIAR
WITH A WOMAN, WITH A FEMALE OR
MEN STRAGHTD PERSON'S BODY.
I'M SORRY WE HAVE TO BREAK IT
DOWN ON, YOU KNOW, BREAK DOWN
BIOLOGY 101 ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION.
>> Rachel: SHE IS TALKING ABOUT
GREG ABBOTT.
BUT SHE IS ALSO TALKING ABOUT
MEN STRAIGHTING PERSONS.
DO YOU KNOW ANYBODY OTHER THAN
WOMEN WHO.
>> SHE IS SUCH A FAKE FEMINIST
THAT SHE WOULD BRING UP AN ISSUE
LIKE THIS AND TRY USE IT TO MAKE
SOME KIND OF POLITICAL POINT.
THAT'S NOT EQUALITY, RIGHT?
OH, MAN, DON'T EVEN GET ME
STARTED ON THIS.
THIS MAKES MY STOMACH SICK WHAT
SHE HAS SAID.
SHE SHOULD BE EMBARRASSED TO
EVEN HAVE TRIED TO BRING UP AN
ISSUE LIKE THAT AND MAKE HER
POLITICAL POINT.
SHE IS SO OFF BASE POLITICALLY
BUT OFF BASE EVEN IN THIS
ANALOGY OR WHATEVER IT IS THAT
SHE IS THROWING OUT THERE.
SHE IS MILKING THE WHOLE FEMALE
THING AND AS A REAL FEMINIST I'M
EMBARRASSED FOR HER.
A REAL FEMINIST IS ONE WHO KNOWS
THEY ARE CAPABLE AND DOING A LOT
MORE THAN AOC GIVES WOMEN'S
CREDIT FOR.
YES, WE CAN GIVE LIFE TO A CHILD
AND AT THE SAME TIME PURSUE
EDUCATION AND PURSUE CAREERS AND
TAKE CARE OF OUR OTHER CHILDREN
OR GIVE A CHILD UP FOR ADOPTION
IF WE DO NOT FEEL THAT WE CAN
TAKE CARE OF THAT CHILD.
SHE MASS NO IDEA.
SHE HAS NO -- HER WORLD VIEW IS
THIS BIG.
SHE HAS NO IDEA WHAT IT IS LIKE
TO BE A MOTHER OF A SPECIAL
NEEDS CHILD.
WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE A MOTHER OF
A VETERAN.
WHAT IT IS LIKE TO BE THE MOTHER
OF A TEENAGE DAUGHTER WHO FINDS
HERSELF IN LESS THAN IDEAL
CIRCUMSTANCE ALL THESE THINGS
THAT THE REST OF AMERICA WE DO.
WE DO FACE.
AND WE'RE ABLE THEN TO MAKE
JUDGMENTS AND MAKE OUR JUDGES ON
THE LIFE EXPERIENCES.
SHE HAS GOT THIS MUCH.
AND SHE IS RUNNING THE SHOW?
>> Rachel: WELL, GOVERNOR, YOU
HAVE HAD ALL THOSE EXPERIENCES
AND THAT'S WHY PEOPLE LIKE YOU.
YOU TELL IT LIKE IT IS.
REALLY GRATEFUL THAT YOU WOULD
COME ON MY SHOW TONIGHT.
THANK YOU, GOVERNOR.
>> YOU ARE DOING A GRE